next question today is hey do you
believe that any state is going to flip
party in the 2020 presidential election
from the 2016 results there's actually a
much bigger conversation to be had here
but first let's think it through I think
Arizona is certainly a possibility
Donald Trump is the Democrats had a very
strong showing in Arizona during the
midterms and polling is looking very
strong in Arizona so Arizona is a
possibility that that might flip in 2020
when we talk about key states that went
to trump by a little bit but in 2016 but
could go the other way North Carolina is
certainly a possibility George is a
possibility although less likely I think
if Georgia goes blue in 2020 it will be
a landslide against Donald Trump I find
it hard to believe there would be a
situation where Georgia is isolated as a
state that flips and otherwise the
election is basically as in 2016 even
though we have 50 individual elections
there are still trends and there is
still momentum and I think if Georgia
goes blue it a lot of other things will
go blue as well I think it's conceivable
that Minnesota if you want to find a
blue state that could go to trump it's
possible Minnesota has been sort of
right leaning a little bit lately and
the numbers are not looking as cleanly
positive for the eventual Democratic
nominee I don't think that it's super
likely there are people talking about
New Hampshire as well I think that
there's actually another interesting
possibility if we want to so look at
Florida for example Florida is a state
that is a very important state in many
elections because it sometimes goes to
the Democrats sometimes it goes to the
Republican and it's often pretty close I
think that in 2020 we could have a
pretty wacky result where the popular
vote results are very similar to 2016
and that the Democratic challenger will
win by several million votes but you
could either have a trump re-election
with a similar electoral vote margin as
in 2016
or you could have a very similar popular
vote result and a Democratic win if some
key states like for example there there
was a map I was looking at Florida and
Ohio could remain with Trump but he
could still lose electoral II and there
are some pretty wacky maps that have
been put together that are at least
conceivably plausible based on state
polling right now um but if I had to say
what is the the most likely flip
I think it's Arizona to go blue North
Carolina maybe to go blue the governor
there is somewhat popular and I I think
the one thing to consider when we look
at these numbers is that because there
is no democratic nominee yet the
Republican propaganda machine has not
yet been able to just focus on any one
Democratic candidate whereas every
Democratic candidate has been talking
about Donald Trump sometimes even during
the debates Democratic candidates won't
even talk about their own policy they
will just they'll be asked a question
about what they would do and they will
just criticize Donald Trump we've seen
Pete Buddha judge do it we've seen comel
Harris do it I won't list everybody
because almost everyone has done it at
least at some point during the debates I
think the most likely scenario in 2020
is very similar results nationally in
the popular vote and close results in
some of these key states which might go
the other way this time so I think that
if a Democratic candidate is going to
win and defeat Trump in November of 2020
you will see a similar popular vote win
as we saw in 2016 two three four million
votes something like that but you will
see small margins go the other way in
those few key states that that made it
for Trump it was Wisconsin
it was Michigan Pennsylvania North
Carolina that's where I think you will
see this election won or lost it's not a
reason to ignore other places you still
got to work in other places but I think
ultimately small margins in those key
states are going to be the
difference-maker